où
[Musique]
on
oh
m
[Musique]
quand on
mais pourquoi
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en vue de la crise nous
avons dû changer nos activités et nous
en tournée vers la destination pur
d'alcool pour pouvoir apporter combler
le manque qu'il existe aujourd'hui sur
le sol belge et donc nous vendons cet
alcool directement aux pharmacies
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça fait 1 déjà plusieurs de faire
quasiment depuis le début de la crise
que des difficultés d'approvisionnement
en produits pour réaliser les gels
hydroalcooliques jamais pensé
il ya quelques quelques semaines de cela
qu jeu sera amené à venir jusqu'ici pour
pour trouver une
une prison d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]